this week on the climate Show with Tom
Heap Welcome to the Jungle or more
specifically a very wet Woodland on
Dartmoor that qualifies as a rainforest
and I love it
[Music]
hello do join me for our first program
of 2023 where as you can see we've
turfed ourselves out of the studio to
come to this Lush Woodland it's at the
heart of the Dartmoor National Park and
temperate rainforest like this used to
be pretty common in the UK and today on
the show we're going to look at how they
could be expanded to provide more
habitat and store more carbon
but much as I love this place being warm
and dry next to an open fire also feels
powerfully attractive and we hear about
a new public information campaign
encouraging us to think twice before
lighting the burners
up to one-fifth of Britain could have
been covered by rainforests like this
that I'm splashing through now they may
lack the raucous monkeys and alarming
bugs of their tropical cousins but they
are rare and Lively places they've been
reduced to fragments due to the
pressures of farming grazing and
harvesting Timber and I'm about to meet
a couple of people who really want to
revitalize and protect these places
this is long Ash wood on Dartmoor to
qualify as a rainforest it must get at
least a meter and a half of rainfall
every year a good chunk of that has
fallen in the past 24 hours
I just feel so alive I feel incredibly
inspired by all this life that's
surrounding us you know by the Mosses
the lichens the polypody ferns that are
sprouting out of these old oak trees and
the bilbrey bushes that are starting to
grow around this it is energizing isn't
it it's the the Raging River the life
it's almost sort of Garden of Eden isn't
it you know they just glow green this is
a wood in winter but it's incredibly
green and verdant even at this time of
year
outside of Britain temperate rainforests
are found beside the Pacific Ocean in
New Zealand Japan Chile and the American
Northwest
here this is the area where they once
grew and weather conditions are right
for them to grow again but these are the
fragments that Now cover less than one
percent of Britain
well let's go and have a look at some of
the things you particularly love let's
go let's go and have a look
environmental campaigner guy shrubsol
has just written a book on the Lost
rainforest of Britain what about these
ferns growing off here these are yeah
these are these are wonderful polypody
ferns that grow on trees and and they're
called epiphytes plants that grow on
other plants so you've got mosses living
and dying on the same branches over
Generations forming this sort of
soil-like substance on the branches into
which the other plants are starting to
put their roots
what really makes up Britain's
rainforests are a mix of species but
particularly we find Atlantic oakwoods
so a lot of these trees here are old
yeah oak trees in there yeah but what
we've also got are even rarer uh what
are known as Atlantic hazelwoods and you
get those particularly in places like
the west coast of Scotland but there are
also little pockets of them in the west
country on dartmoor-like here so these
are some beneath all this Moss is
actually a Hazel tree it's just heaving
with lichens I love this so what what's
this black stuff blue green kind of this
is species of lichen called peltidra
sometimes they're called Dog lichens
because on the underside of them they've
got little sharp teeth that look a bit
like dog's teeth and another site just
looking at that Branch there you see it
with all of those Ivy Roots around it it
looks like something that was created by
the I don't know the Harry Potter set
dresser yeah yeah they're wonderfully
kind of gnarled and twisted trees that
you get up here so I found something up
here that I really want to show you
that's very exciting it's this orange
fungus growing here
it's called Hazel gloves fungus and it's
got these little orange hands kind of
clasping the branch
what I'd like to see is is more more
done to support farmers and landowners
to reduce grazing pressure on the edges
of our temperate rainforests and sort of
create buffer zones in which they can
expand again how wide would you like
that to be I'd say 100 150 meters around
our temperate rainforest if we did that
we could actually double that area
within a generation taking productive
land away from Farmers is often
controversial even with subsidy and that
grazing pressure just farm animals or
deer as well do they need certainly a
problem particularly in Scotland where
there are about a million deer now
marauding around the countryside we
certainly need to be doing a lot more to
control DN numbers and I'm afraid that
does mean in the absence of any other
natural predators that does mean culling
all the rich life In This Place stores
carbon but climate change could threaten
this
so you can see from one set of wrinkles
which is the slowing down in the growth
at the end of the year to the more
expanded area how long the growth has
been in one year if you get a very dry
hot summer like this summer
this can put more pressure on these on
these plants and if you get a succession
of them in a row and these lead to fires
mall and fires which sweep through the
area and maybe encourage pests and
pathogens to survive over winter then
all these pressures together can can be
a massive risk
feels quite otherworldly in a way
doesn't it yes I think you can see why
the Druids liked it
but enlarging these places where so many
Wild Things Are would make them more
resilient I think it's not unrealistic
to look to double the size of England's
temperate rainforest rainforest that you
can see touch smell really feel not just
watch on your Telly and not have to go
all the way to the Amazon to see
is our last program a month ago we've
had a deluge of climate news from
freezing temperatures across the Center
of America to a barbecue winter in the
Alps and protesters in Germany trying to
stop the expansion of a massive coal
mine seems like time for the year's
first edition of the TomTom show that's
me catching up with our sons
correspondent Thomas Moore
nice weather for us on our park bench
what's been happening around the world
over the last few weeks lots more weird
weather so you've got very low
temperatures as far south as Florida on
the other side of the Atlantic and very
warm weather on this side of the
Atlantic with many countries breaking
their records for January temperatures
in Warsaw for example 18 degrees four
degrees warmer than their previous
records so blown it completely out of
the park and it's that kind of
shattering the annihilation of Records
like that that really makes climate
scientists think that this is really
changing very rapidly indeed and very
little snow in the Alps over the the
Christmas skiing period are these things
linked this cold in America warm in
Europe so it's to do with the the
wiggliness of the jet stream those high
altitude winds that when things are
going well they whip around in a nice
tight Circle but as things break down
and that has something to do with glow
with warming in the Arctic it's warming
three or four times faster than the rest
of the planet tends to meander more and
if you're on the south side of this
these waving winds then you tend to get
much warmer weather so for example uh in
in Europe that Drew up hot air from from
West Africa and also with the the very
warm sea temperatures this time of year
unusually so that led to the blistering
heat comparatively in in um in in
January just briefly in Germany despite
what we've been having in the weather in
Germany often talking the language on
climate change they're expanding a coma
and this really does illustrate the
difficulties that many countries are
having because of what's happened in
Ukraine and trying to move away from gas
as rapidly as possible to keep the
lights on Germany is actually expanding
this really dirty Coal Mine they're
using lignite which is the dirtiest form
of coal and of course coal is the
dirtiest form of fossil fuel and
expanding it quite dramatically and and
there is this big issue at the moment of
police removing environmental activists
and and it's leading to a real
confrontation in more kind of confusing
signals news the next cop the big
climate Summit the chair is is someone
who runs an oil company I mean this is
feels like fox in charge of the hen
house time yeah look I mean this this
next climate conference is going to be
uh in in Dubai which uh caused quite a
few hiccups around the world uh because
of course that is you know the center of
the oil Universe yes absolutely right
and indeed now so the the chief
executive of the Abu Dhabi National oil
company uh is going to be the president
of the summit um and that has led to a
lot of environmental acts they're saying
that this is
um just untenable well while we're on
the oil company there's also been some
news about Exxon Mobil I think that over
the time they were one of the biggest
corporates out there doing well that
they their scientists knew all along and
predicted about the effect that fossil
fuels would have on climate yes this is
research done by Harvard and by Potsdam
the climate research group in in Germany
and they've Unearthed this Trove of
documents going back to the 90 1970s
suggesting that privately Exxon was well
aware of what was going on that there
would be this predictable increase in
both global temperatures and in in
carbon dioxide concentrations in the
atmosphere and of course that's traced
back to fossil fuels while at the same
time they were denying it and that
denial continued into the century I
gather they that they deny it they say
very strongly that they weren't as
certain as that and are committed to
tackling climate change we must bring it
home
um there was a review that was announced
when Liz truss as prime minister about
our journey to Net Zero that review has
now come out well they've got some
pretty strong thought yes indeed and the
suspicion of many environmental groups
was at the time that Liz truss was using
this as an excuse to row back on the net
zero commitments but in fact Chris
Skidmore Tory MP has has he's doubled
down the review indeed he's doubled down
I mean he's saying the risks of not zero
are greater than Net Zero that this is
The Economic Opportunity of the century
he says and he comes up with 25
different things that need to be done uh
by 2025 which is when the parliament
ends and and they include like a moving
rapidly into onshore wind going into a
revolution in rooftop solar to increase
the amount of energy we get from the Sun
there should be Eco labeling on on food
so that people know the the footprint of
of the the food that they eat some
really interesting ideas and they're
saying that households could save
between 400 and 6 000 pounds a year by
shifting towards green energy inside
after the break we'll be answering some
of your questions and a new campaign is
asking us to light the log burner less
often due to its impact on air quality
government data suggests they could be
worse than traffic when it comes to
those small particles that can be bad
for our health a real risk or just kill
Joy environmentalism come back to us
after the break
[Music]
welcome back and I've come off the more
now and I'm looking forward to getting
Far Side in this Pub but could the fire
the burning of those logs be doing more
damage to our air in terms of pollution
than we realize his Sky's correspondent
Matthew Thompson
stoves have exploded in popularity
sales are up by two-thirds in the last
year alone
partly that's driven by Trends in
interior design but also increasingly as
a practical response to the soaring cost
of energy Ian Murr runs his business
from home and this winter has found
himself using his burner more than usual
we've turned our heating down quite low
and then we try to stay in just you know
the kind of rooms with the wood burner
where the heat comes out from there as
the price of gas and energy has just
soared then we've definitely become
quite reliant on it I'll probably try
and work in this room so and just keep a
little bit warmer and yeah we really try
and keep those energy bills down
the low costs may be attractive but
domestic wood burning comes with costs
of a different kind it produces more of
a dangerous source of air pollution
called PM 2.5 than all the cars on the
road
breathing PM 2.5 is responsible for
somewhere around 20 to 30 000 extra
deaths in the UK each year when it comes
to wood burning we think that around 17
of the PM 2.5 that is being produced in
the UK is coming from people burning
wood the best way to see the health
impact of air pollution is to look at
those places where they've taken burning
away there's less weeds in the children
in those communities there's less people
attending hospital for heart respiratory
problems
new research commissioned by global
action plan as part of a new awareness
campaign suggests few people know just
High polluting burning wood can be
and even when they do have some
awareness the impact was typically seen
to be small compared to things like
traffic and heavy industry the research
also find that most people using burners
do so for aesthetic purposes with only a
relatively small proportion using it as
their main source of heating
and it find that people who use burners
often show skepticism about the impact
of their stoves we're launching this
campaign to help provide information to
people who already have a wood burner
the information isn't out there at the
moment there isn't a public conversation
about the health impacts of wood burning
so I think people need to know this
this is my son's bedroom
and every evening and morning he does
his preventer inhaler but whilst
changing Minds could take time those
particularly sensitive to air pollution
like Ruth's heavily asthmatic Sun are
living with the consequences here and
now I can frequently smell wood smoke in
his bedroom and I've plugged up there's
an old kind of Edwardian
event that my son was a bit Wheezy not
too badly but I put him to bed in a room
that smelled of smoke and I just thought
how wrong it was that you know
not only is he breathing it in outside
but now you know we're at home in what's
supposed to be kind of a safe
environment and there is absolutely
nothing I can do
the government said it has already acted
to regulate wood burners and to ban more
polluting fuels the stove industry
Alliance said modern designs produce
significantly less PM 2.5 than open
fires and are a cost-effective way to
heat a home
for some wood burning is a necessity for
others it is a choice
by making the dangers of that choice
plain campaigners hope that public
enthusiasm for this achingly trendy
accessory slowly Burns itself out
Matthew Thompson Sky News
well to talk through this I'm joined Far
Side of course by environmental writer
George mombio and just a little
confession I'm a bit of a fan of the
flame to heat my own home indeed my
publicity picture shows me next to a
wood pile so not much hiding there but
George do you feel comfy next to the
Hearth well it feels great doesn't it it
does give you literally a warm glow to
to sit beside the fire but
and yeah I installed wood burners myself
years ago thinking it was the right
thing to do but as the evidence has
accumulated it's very clear that it's
the wrong thing to do what evidence are
you pointing at so this is about
pollution it's about outdoor pollution
and it's about indoor pollution it's
about the extraordinary level of
particulates tiny little particles of
soot and other materials produced by
wood burning stoves
um we we know now know that they make a
very major contribution to outdoor
pollution we know less about the impact
on indoor pollution but it seems to be
very high indeed in fact if you've got a
wood burning stove in your house it's
almost certainly the major cause of
indoor pollution and could be having a
very significant impact on your health
we'll be breathing it in now we're
breathing it in now um open fires are
even worse than wood burning stoves but
however carefully you use a wood burner
you will have to open the door from time
to time time to refuel and as one study
shows when you do so there's a flood of
these little tiny particulates coming
out into your house and into your lungs
and affecting every organ in your body
it seems to me a little context is
important here air pollution including
these PM 2.5 is a dangerous smaller
particles have been going down quite
steeply and quite successfully on recent
years so the threat from air pollution
is lower than it was so is it really
such a big risk well it depends which
study you look at because one study
suggests that even though only eight
percent of people have wood burners it
produces more particulate pollution than
all the vehicles on the road that's
partly because vehicles have gone down
so much yes the story of vehicle success
well well that's right and so we thought
we were cleaning up the air but as we
are as Vehicles as vehicle particulates
have gone down wood particulates been
rising as more and more people have been
installing wood burning stoves and so
what we see then is a massively
disproportionate impact of the small
number of households which are using
these stoves which has to be said is
generally middle-class households
this is always a slight question of the
lesser of two or more evils isn't it
because certainly my view when I uh put
in a wood burning stove was I don't want
to take fossil carbon out of the ground
there's a whole message you have a keep
it in the ground and wood the wood
behind you is in the biosphere it's
being cycled round and there's a
principle that felt better to me yeah
well that was exactly my view as well
that's why years ago I installed wood
burners too I thought it was the right
thing to do I wanted to unhook myself
from burning gas and Home Heating is
difficult there's no question about that
it's expensive it's difficult there are
a few good ways of doing it but if I
were to make those decisions today I
would install a heat pump rather than
wood burning stoves because in that way
you can both cut out the fossil fuels
and the huge amount of pollution now
involved in stoves what do you want to
see happen to wood burning stoves so um
I want to see the sale of these stoves
band band yep band and the same goes for
pellet boilers I want to see that band
as well and I want to see the use of
these stoves phased out with with help
for those people who've got no other
form of heating that's that that's
important you know there are some people
who have come to depend on those stoves
they will need government help but a lot
of people have them for aesthetic
reasons we should be phasing that out it
is not fair to be exposing other people
to your pollution because you like the
Warm Glow of sitting by a fire is it
really justifiable to put a ban in place
well look wood burners have got more
efficient in the same way that the
guillotine was more efficient than the
ax for chopping off people's heads they
still do you great harm I'm not saying
that everyone who's exposed to a wood
burner is killed by it but we are as a
population being harmed by wood burning
stoves that's undeniable it's foolish to
try to deny that obvious truth well
thank you very much George and now we've
got time for some of your question and
the first one comes from Abdi Aziz auror
who asks in Somalia climate change is
real although its carbon footprint is
less than
.002 percent of global emissions but as
it is one of the most vulnerable
countries to climate change how can the
Somali government get climate finance
and Justice we asked Professor salimu
hook to answer this one for you thank
you very much for the question Abdullah
it's a very good question in fact
Somalia has one of the lowest carbon
Footprints as you uh mentioned and is
one of the most vulnerable countries to
the impacts of climate change along with
many other poor countries so last year
in prop 27 in Egypt we actually
succeeded in getting all countries
including the rich countries to agree to
set up a new fund called The Lost and
damage fund to provide support to the
victims of climate change like Somalia
this fund is now going to be set up and
hopefully get up and running very soon
and at that point Somalia will be able
to apply to get funding and now on to a
question from Corey who asks how will
the mining for minerals that are used in
electric vehicles for Batteries affect
the climate and environment
hi Corey thanks for your question the
key thing to focus on here is life cycle
emissions that's the total emissions
emitted by a car over its lifetime that
comes from both driving it and from
building it
um firstly you need to bear in mind that
a majority of a vehicle's emissions come
from the driving of it rather than the
building of it and secondly because it's
powered by electricity rather than
burning fuel an ev's total life cycle
emissions are therefore much lower than
a conventional petrol equivalent car
now before we go just time for some good
news Britain broke its record again on
Tuesday for power generation from wind
with turbines consistently providing
around half of all our electricity this
week according to the National Grid it's
helped to cut our Reliance on gas for
power generation reducing emissions as
well as the amount the government is
shelling out to support households with
their bills this winter
well that's all we've got time for this
week from Devon but remember you can
catch up with the daily climate show
weekdays at 3 30 on Sky News and keep
across all our climate coverage on the
website or the Sky News app but for now
see you next week
foreign
[Music]